this is a really interesting idea of
bugs per line of code
if you look at all the computer systems
out there from the code that runs
nuclear weapons to the code that runs
all the amazing companies that you've
been involved with and not the code that
runs Twitter and Facebook and Dropbox
and Google and Microsoft Windows and so
on
and we like laid out
wouldn't that be a cool like table bugs
per line of code and what let's let's
put like actual companies aside
do you think we'd be surprised by the
number we see there for all these
companies
that depends on whether you've ever read
about research that's been done in this
area before
and
I didn't know that the re the the last
time I
I saw some research like that there was
probably in the 90s and the research
might have been done in the 80s
but the the conclusion was across a wide
range of different software different
languages
different companies
different development styles
the number of bugs is always
I think it's in the order of about one
bug per thousand lines in sort of
mature software that that is considered
interesting as good as it gets can give
you some facts here there's a lot of
good papers so you said mature software
right so here's uh
a report from a uh like programming
analytics company
now this is from a developer perspective
let me just say what it says because
this is very weird and surprising on
average a developer creates 70 bugs per
1000 lines of code
15 bugs per 1000 lines of code find
their way to the customers
this is in the software they've oh I was
I was wrong by an order
fixing a bug takes 30 times longer than
writing a line of code that I can
believe yeah 75 of a developer's time is
spent on debugging
um that's for an average developer they
Analyze This 15 argue one 1500 hours a
year in us alone
113 billion dollars to spend annually on
identifying and fixing bugs
and I imagine this is marketing
literature for someone who claims to
have a golden bullet or a silver bullet
that makes all that investment in fixing
bugs go away but that that is usually uh
not going to yeah that's not gonna
happen well they're uh I mean they're
referencing a lot of stuff of course but
it is a page uh that is you know there's
a contact us button at the bottom
presumably if you just spend a little
bit less than 100 billion dollars we're
willing to solve the problem for you
right and there's also a report on stock
exchanges stack overflow on the exact
same topic but when I open it up at the
moment the page says stack Overflow is
currently offline for maintenance oh
it's ironic yes uh by the way their
error page is awesome anyway
I mean can you believe that number of
bugs oh absolutely isn't that scary that
70 bucks per 1000 lines of code so even
10 bucks per thousand lives well that's
about one bug after every 15 lines and
that's when you're first typing it in
yeah from a developer but like how many
bugs are going to be found
if you're if you're typing well the
development process is extremely
iterative yeah typically you don't make
a plan for what software you're going to
release a year from now yeah uh and work
out all the details because actually all
the details uh themselves consist
they're sort of compose a program
and that that
being a program all your plans will have
bugs in them too and inaccuracies
uh but what what you actually do is
you do a bunch of typing and I'm I'm
actually really I'm a really bad typist
that just I've never learned to type
with 10 fingers
how many do you use
well I could use all 10 of them but not
very well
but I I never I never took a talking
class and I never sort of corrected that
so the first time I I seriously learned
I I had to learn the layout of a qwerty
keyboard
was actually in college in my first
programming classes where we used Punch
Cards
and so
with my two fingers I sort of pecked out
my code
watch anyone
give you a little coding demonstration
they'll have to produce like four lines
of code
and now see how many times they use the
backspace key yeah because they made a
mistake and and
and some people especially when when
someone else is looking
will will backspace over 20 30 40
characters to fix a typo earlier in a
line if you're
if you're slightly more experienced of
course you use your arrow buttons to go
or your mouse to but the mouse is
usually slower than uh than the arrows
but a lot of people when they type a 20
character word which is not unusual and
they realize they made us made a mistake
at the start of the word the backspace
over the whole thing
and then retype it and sometimes it
takes three four times to get it right
so
I don't know what your definition of bug
is arguably mistyping a word and then
correcting it immediately is not a bug
on the other hand you you already
do sort of lose time and every once in a
while there's sort of a typo that you
don't get in that process
and now you've you've typed like 10
lines of code uh and some were in the
middle of it you don't know where yet is
a typo or maybe a finco where you you
forgot that you had to initialize a
variable or something but those are two
different things and I would say yes you
have to actually run the code to
discover that typo but forgetting to
initialize a variable is a fundamentally
different thing because that thing could
go undiscovered uh that depends on the
language in Python it will not right in
sort of modern compilers are usually
pretty good at catching that even
even foresee so for that specific thing
but actually deeper
it might there might be another variable
that has initialized but logically
speaking the one you meant related yep
it's like name the same but it's a
different thing and you forgot to
initialize uh whatever some counter or
some some basic variable they're using I
can tell that you've coded yes by the
way I should mention that I use the
Kinesis keyboard
which has the backspace under the thumb
and one of the biggest reasons I use
that keyboard is because you realize in
order to use the backspace on a usual
keyboard you have to stretch your pinky
out
and like the the for most normal
keyboards the Backspaces under the pinky
and so I don't know if people realize
the pain they go through in their life
because of the backspace keep being so
far away so with the Kinesis it's right
under the thumb so you don't have to
actually move your hands the backspace
and the delivery what do you do if
you're ever not with your own keyboard
and you have to use someone else's PC
keyboard that has a standard layout so
first of all it turns out that you can
actually go your whole life always
having the keyboard
with you so this well except for that
that little tablet that you're using so
we're note taking right now right uh
yeah so it's very inefficient
note-taking but I'm not I'm just looking
stuff up but in most cases I would be
actually using the keyboard here right
now I just don't anticipate you have to
calculate how much typing do you
anticipate if I anticipate quite a bit
then I'll just I have a keyboard and the
same same with I mean
the embarrassing
of accepted being the weirdo that I am
but you know when I go on an airplane
and I anticipate to do programming or a
lot of typing I will have a laptop that
will put pull out a Kinesis keyboard in
addition to the laptop and it's just who
I am you have to you have to accept who
you are
um but also it's a you know for a lot of
people
for me certainly there's a comfort space
where there's a certain kind of setups
that are maximized productivity
and
um it's like some people have a warm
blanket that they like when they watch a
movie I like the Kinesis keyboard takes
me to uh a place of focus and I still
mostly I I'm trying to make sure I use
the state-of-the-art IDS for everything
but my comfort place just like the
Kinesis keyboard is still emacs
so
I still use that I still I mean that's
one of some of the debates I have with
myself about everything from a
technology perspective
is how much to hold on to the tools
you're comfortable with versus how much
to invest in using modern tools and the
signal that the communities provide you
with is the noisy one because a lot of
people year to year get excited about
new tools and you have to make a
prediction are these tools defining a
new generation or something that will
transform programming or is this just a
fad that will pass